foi minha praia a criatividade a
literatura e sobretudo liberdade de
expressão
o jogo crianças e adolescentes escreveu
para o livro a ilustrar a fazer um
protótipo da capa ea publicação
significa que cada um precisa passar
pelo percurso área da escrita de
escolher o seu heróis e heroínas de
quais são os conflitos têm que entrar em
crise de escrever de fato do começo até
o ponto final e não só o protótipo a
entidade literária mas a visual também
como é que vai ser a capa quais são as
ilustrações como é que vai ser o
protótipo do livro de jogar pro
computador essas ilustrações é cortar o
fundo escolher onde vai ficar o título
qualquer a fonte que a gente vai colocar
e o vídeo traz o voo continuou eu pausa
também a grande
o grande percurso é tirar as idéias e
colocar no papel e que eles virem livros
não só um mas dezenas de livros e então
o vôo hall
eu tinha os amigos vizinhos pra celebrar
a criatividade numa festa de autógrafos
o primeiro livro é isso na verdade
e aí em escola particular deu muito
certo mas chegou a hora de quebrar
barreiras e vamos em direção a um ensino
público e encontrei é mãe alcoólatra os
presos mãe que doou filho para o vizinho
cuidar do filho que entrou na justiça
contra a própria mãe teve problemas
graves de influenza
futuras acesso precário a internet mas
mas nada disso era um empecilho pra para
que brotasse um criatividade para que
estes livros fossem publicados para que
a autoria estivesse ali na mão de cada
estudante para fazer acontecer
mas a história tem tem vilões e por trás
desse livro em quadrinhos do michael em
vilões que somos nós os adultos
atrapalham o percurso da liberdade
é sobre isso que eu quero falar um
pouquinho sobre os adultos não saberem
ser em alguns imaginam que você
professor ou professora de uma menina de
11 anos e você vai acompanhar ele o
trabalho literário dela e vai se deparar
o comecinho do terceiro capítulo novo
ano
a nova sala novos alunos nova vida uma
aposta e aí eu proíbo ou não como
professor ou professora como coordenador
mas há dúvidas vezes nem está dentro da
gente a gente já dá uma lição de moral a
gente já proíbe nome de alguma coisa
sempre tem alguma coisa maior para
proteger a criança e se a gente para
realmente pra ler o texto para tentar
conhecer a menina por trás do texto
a gente percebe novo ano vírgula nova
sala vírgula novos alunos reticências
nova vida ponto
a gente percebe a repetição das palavras
do novo nova novos nova apontou como
gente grande ao trabalho a expectativa
do leitor ela tem um senso de ironia a
gente está preocupado com uma bosta
frágil da a refletir sobre essa questão
uma outra aluna vai vai aparecer aí ela
de um projeto lindo lindo que chama o
projecto âncora que dá muita autonomia e
dá muita liberdade na mão das crianças
o jornalista faz uma pergunta delicada
com elas
tudo bem no microcosmos dentro de uma
escola pode funcionar pode dar certo mas
e se a gente quiser escalar a gente
quiser que todo o município tem escolas
assim todo o estado
o brasil inteiro de dificuldade e vi um
absurdo
e por que só os mais velhos é muito bom
ele tem é ea escola do que as crianças
eu acho que sim é possível mas ela
também acho que nós adultos colocamos as
crianças numa situação cronicamente
passiva concussão caso estado de são
paulo antiga febem unidade de internação
de jovens infratores
vamos fazer o primeiro livro lá dentro
vamos quebrar mais barreiras
ele tem um menino que já roubou porque
tinha fome e rolou para comprar pó já
traficou pra comprar a moto e roubou
moto pra ir no baile funk
já o celular carro carga já matou o
menino que tem um repertório cultural
que é muito muito muito muito distante
disse capella menina caxeta se do leste
disse joão pedro vê esse produtor r7 ele
se tinha o robinho pedrinho juninho
felipe boladão roteiro que a gente não
sobe mais da vontade de falar meu
o dia vai à noite vem não muda nada na
febem medida socioeducativa
não muda a minha vida
como tem um outro jovem ele se disse
albert einstein pra dar uma palhinha pra
gente
ele um pouquinho mais adulto refletiu
também sobre liberdade
ele também escreveu sobre a educação
a gente não sabe mas ele disse que por
liberdade
entendo condições sociais de tal
qualidade que a expressão de opiniões e
afirmações sobre assuntos gerais ou
particulares do conhecimento não
acarreta em perigo ou grandes
desvantagens para quem as faz
beleza a gente tem um ambiente tolerante
ambiente livre
ele deixa ali naquele local independente
de alguém mais velho poder falar num
para aquilo é um ambiente profundamente
intolerante
mas olha para frente ele fala sobre as
escolas se as escolas podem prejudicar o
desenvolvimento da liberdade interior
através das influências autoritárias e
através da imposição aos jovens de
cargas espirituais cargos federais aqui
não como religião mas como uma
mentalidade engessada um quadrado na
sala de aula no quadro das disciplinas
no quadrado do espaço e do tempo em que
a gente se coloca é que a gente quer
colocar as crianças também é outro
grande autor o igor
ele refletiu sobre essas palavras do
einstein mas só ali na prática esse
livro é um livro autobiográfico ele
conta a experiência do próprio ato
infracional ele conta ali no começo do
livro o ato dele e lhe roubou uma moto
porque hoje no baile de moto é progresso
empresa
a polícia chegou ele vai pro primeiro
centro de atendimento ao jovem infrator
onde ele vai poder conversar com um
advogado e o advogado vai perguntar pra
ele por qual motivo ele desferiu baile
funk com
os parceiros e pegaram as mulheres é
honesto ele diz a verdade
mas ele leva uma grande bronca leva um
grande presta atenção uma lição de moral
daí ele vai para uma unidade de
internação provisória onde vai poder
conversar com um promotor que vai fazer
a mesma pergunta pra ele
por qual motivo você roubou a moto e ele
diz o be a moto para arrumar a moto do
meu parceiro vai trabalhar na pizzaria o
discurso surgindo mesmo assim ele também
leva uma bronca
nossa ele vai começar a aprender como é
que funciona vai conversar com a juíza
que pergunta por qual motivo e ele
responde
iremos trabalhar na pizzaria que o motor
da moto do meu parceiro estava travado e
precisamos de outro motor e decidimos
roubar a verdade dos fatos
é verdade que a gente quer ouvir a dupla
realidade ea é é as duas pontas do
sistema que eu quero olhar para o
meio-de-campo tolerante para que os
meninos e as meninas possam criar e se
sentir livres ali dentro
a gente não sabe voltando pro michael no
seu livro em quadrinhos que a gente deve
conversar com os adultos por trás
a professora achava que o quadrinho não
era literatura então ele não podia
escrever é bom assim é simples assim mas
acontece
a tati que a aluna com necessidades
especiais também a gente teve que
conversar com a coordenação com a
direcção pra convencer os adultos de que
as crianças dependentes das suas
necessidades
podem também escrever seu livro junto
com as outras crianças tidos como
normais nunca vi ninguém normal até hoje
a imagina quantas conversas então dentro
da febem da fundação casa
a fundação casa evoluiu o meu grau de
ódio os alunos colocou na capa
mas é possível a gente tem com o diálogo
com a conversa consegue conquistar
território e através desses territórios
que a gente conquista
a gente tá ali preservando os nossos
princípios por trás e aí surgem pérolas
ness o filho vitor felipe nasceu parto
caseiro filho de um padeiro que vivia
sem dinheiro compara empresário cresceu
victor se desenvolveu em direito se
formou
victor se tornou deputado felipe cita no
ladrão um roubava de estado outro com
arma na mão
a liberdade de expressão
então a gente começou a conquistar
espaço então vamos colocar na capa
desses meninos
o nome real vamos colocar na orelha a
foto real deles precisa conversar com
adultos cejas e então vamos conversar
com os juízes mas se a gente consegue
vamos fazer uma festa de autógrafos numa
biblioteca pública então e tirá los
temporariamente da dengue houve não não
não não não sim aí a partir dos índios
vai atrás conversa com o juiz conversa
com o advogado confessa com a
superintendência coordenadoria com
diretoria e acontece então imagina essa
festa de autógrafos com familiares numa
biblioteca pública
um dos diretores de um dos centros falou
vamos transportá los sem algemas então
são beleza
imagina nessa festa de autógrafo
um dos meninos resolve pegar o microfone
com todo mundo ali sentado autoridades
familiares e desabafar
olha só uma adolescente sabe eu quero
deixar bem claro foi a nação cada que o
mundo
fui eu quem quis jogar tudo o que
encontrei a mudança de mim foi que eu
voltei pra mim joga até o fim só tem
muitas pessoas me ajudaram a afundar são
paulo
aí silêncio a presidente estadual da
fundação casa levanta vem são paulo pega
o microfone como fundo ali na cadeira da
boa hora vai ter desacatado a lição de
moral a gente ultrapassar os limites mas
ela concordou com ele
ela disse que como instituição
a grande maioria dos meninos não
conseguiam perceber como a fundação casa
poderia ajudá los
muito pelo contrário como atrapalhava de
que isso é um problema
ela também discordou dele dizendo que
aquele ambiente propício tolerante como
einstein imaginou foi propiciado também
com a ajuda da instituição e que ele não
enxergava aquela ajuda mas o mais
importante aqui está acontecendo um
diálogo tolerante
entre as duas pontas do discurso da
realidade e da hierarquia de cima para
baixo e aí eu já tinha ganhado no meu aí
o joão continuou ele
em um discurso bonito ele fez
pessoalmente também quando quando for
velhinha amargo com com a realidade
eu vou poder ouvir o que ele falou que é
muito muito muito bonita significativa e
comecei a escrever esse livro que ele
tem uma escola que meu dever é interesse
por novidades o luis flores ou a digna
que então aberto que acreditou que foi
lá buscar dentro
são joão mesmo que escreveu o livro o
poeta da vila obrigado mais uma vez é é
isso para mim é essa dignidade nesses
olhos e orgulho de poder falar que este
livro deles do meu lado
hoje eu posso dizer que eu tenho orgulho
de participar do projeto primeiro livro
é nós
uai